and the prostate
is a walnut-sized male gland located at
the base of the bladder and surrounding the
urethra
prostate cancer is one of the
most common cancers in men
radical prostatectomy is a
surgical procedure
that removes  the prostate
peripheral tissue and the seminal vesicles
depending on your case the surgeon
may also choose to remove some
lymph nodes
before undergoing surgery
an intravenous line will be placed
you may be given antibiotics
intravenously to reduce the
chances of  get an infection
you will be given general
spinal or epidural anesthesia if you receive
general anesthesia you will have a breathing tube placed
through your mouth and down your
throat to help you breathe
during the operation
if you receive epidural or spinal anesthesia you will
not need a breathing tube you will be
given  a sedative to help
relax
your prostate  radical surgery can
take 90 minutes to 4 hours
different techniques can be used
open retro public
prostatectomy open perineal prostatectomy and
laparoscopic prostatectomy
in an open retro public
prostatectomy the prostate is removed
through an incision made in
the lower abdomen in a
perineal prostatectomy the prostate is
removed through an incision
made in the perineum
between the rectum and the scrotum in a
laparoscopic prostatectomy
the surgeon inserts the instruments into
the abdominal cavity through
small keyhole incisions
o ports
the surgeon separates the prostate from its
peripheral structure and removes the
gland through one of the
slightly widened ports 2
depending on whether
or not the cancer has spread the
surgeon also removes the tissue
surrounding the prostate including
seminal vesicles and
lymph nodes  Regardless of the type
of procedure,
the surgeon will carefully examine the
area surrounding the prostate before
removing the tissue, taking care to
minimize damage to the nerves
in that area. At the end of the
surgical procedure, a catheter will be placed
in the bladder to maintain it.
drained the catheter will usually be
left in place for 10 days or
up to 2 weeks after surgery
soon after surgery
your breathing tube will be removed and you will be
moved to the
post-surgical recovery area for
monitoring if necessary pain relievers will be given
to you  pain you may
continue to receive intravenous antibiotics
you may need to flush
your bladder intermittently with a
sterile solution to clear
accumulated blood and clots
most patients are discharged within
two days of the procedure